hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
one of the central motifs of saint
augustine's confessions is that of
seeking wisdom seeking to understand
oneself the world
god
other people to make sense of things
and
this is not something that you can just
simply open up a book and find the
answers to in fact you have to figure
out what you're looking for in terms of
answers and then you also have to think
about the the means that you're using to
derive or to
find answers and the testimony in some
cases of those who are providing it to
you so this is a very complicated
matter and it's one that i think many of
us can
relate to in augustine's way where you
know we may think oh we'll take a class
on it or we'll read this book and then
we find that oh that doesn't solve
everything for us and we find that by
putting things to the test by
progressing in time by seeing what
yields what and
i would say that if we want to pick a
place in the confessions where this
first arises early on
it's in chapter four of book three where
we find out that he becomes interested
in cicero and specifically in a text
that had a massive massive influence
throughout antiquity and the early
middle ages but unfortunately
has been
lost to us the hortensius which is an
exhortation to study philosophy and you
know some advice about maybe how one
ought to go about that now we don't have
much of that text other than fragments
some of which actually come from
augustine others of which come from
other writers later on
and we can piece together a sort of
vague picture about what's going on but
we should look at what augustine himself
tells us about it so he says in the
ordinary course of study i'm i'm engaged
in studies i came across a book by
cicero
the book contains his exhortation to
philosophy and is called hortensius so
you know he he runs into an influential
text that other people are saying hey
man you should read this this is really
good stuff
and it has an extraordinary effect on
augustine
so there are some terms in the latin
that can be translated different ways
but what's important here is that a
change
is brought about in augustine
a change in
we can say not in knowledge itself or
wisdom it's not an end product thing
it's more of a motivational change he
tells us that the book changed my
affections effectum in latin the
feelings that he had right and can books
do that well certainly they can
including this book the confessions
what else it turned my prayers to you
lord now we're going to come back to
that because that's a a weird thing to
say a book of philosophy turned
prayers to god
that can happen
and caused me
to have different purposes
and desires so desire is uh does it area
right that can be translated as desires
motivations the things that you value
the other one purposes vota vote is
literally speaking a vow but you could
think of it as a
commitment a
set of priorities a ranking of values
and preferences and that's what this
book does and that's the power of great
literature
in general it can change not only our
you know mind about things oh this is
true this is this is false
it can change the way that we orient
ourselves and that is what cicero's
hortentius is doing so augustine tells
him that it awakens this great desire
a love
for
wisdom
he says all my vain hopes forthwith
became worthless to me and so that stuff
we're going to leave aside well kind of
and with incredible order of heart i
desired
undying wisdom
and he says this is a book i used
differently i didn't use this book to
sharpen my tongue you know i'm
a rhetoric
student but instead
i was you know
using it
or rather it was
changing me so that i could return to
god
and he says
how i burned oh my god how i burned with
desire to fly away from earthly things
and upward to you
yet i did not know what you would do
with me for with you there is
wisdom god is either the possessor of
wisdom or wisdom and so if we're
philosophers that is those who desire
wisdom those who love wisdom
we are seeking that we are seeking you
know whatever is the best the highest
and then he goes on and he says
there are some people who lead others
astray by means of philosophy right and
they falsify their heirs with that great
and beauteous and honest name so you
notice augustine actually thinks
philosophy is a really great thing
when it's the right philosophy and he
brings up something from where we're
going to go next holy scriptures namely
from saint paul a passage that has
caused so much trouble and mix-ups for
so many people over the years because
they don't pay attention to
what is actually
being said there beware lest any man
deceive you through philosophy and vain
deceit according to the tradition of man
according to the elements of the world
and not according to christ for in him
dwells all the fullness of the godhead
corporeally and augustine says
i didn't know these apostolic words
but i was delighted with the exhortation
cicero's exhortation
not only because only because of its
argument i was stirred up and enkindled
and set aflame to love pursue attain and
cash hold of and strongly embrace
wisdom itself not the wisdom of this or
that school
but wisdom itself whatever it is that
the truest schools
are in fact pursuing and i would say
that this section gives you an idea
about augustine's own
project as a christian philosopher right
so
you know
this is this is a good start you can say
and then immediately he talks about the
holy scriptures
and he tells us something really
fascinating he says now you know
augustine is from a
nominally christian family the dad is
not really a christian any sense his mom
is right and so he knows about the holy
scriptures what are the holy scriptures
so we're talking about the
jewish texts right and then the
specifically christian
texts as well and these are viewed as
being part of one big
fabric right
there's you know all sorts of variety in
it there's you know the the first five
books the pentateuch right there's the
histories there's the wisdom literature
there's the prophets in in the the
christian literature we have the gospels
talking about you know the life and
deeds of this guy jesus christ we have
letters we just talked about a letter
from paul we have a few other things as
well like book of acts and
revelations so augustine says
i decided to turn my mind to the holy
scriptures and see what they were like
now
see what they're like why because he
hasn't actually paid any attention to
them up until this time
and he says i see something within them
that was neither revealed to the proud
nor made plain to children
that was lowly on one's entrance
entrance but lofty on further advance
and that was veiled over in mysteries
now this is augustine retrospectively
talking about this not the augustine of
his you know
exiting youth and moving into adulthood
who doesn't really get much out of them
at all why not
he says
none such as i was at that time could
enter into it nor could i bend my neck
for its passageways when i first turned
towards it i did not feel towards it as
i'm speaking now but it seemed unworthy
of comparison with the nobility of
cicero's writings cicero is the real
deal scriptures who knows what that is
it's kind of for ordinary people it's
not orienting me towards something much
greater and so he says my pride turned
away from its humble style my sharp gaze
did not penetrate into its inner meaning
so that's something he explores and then
sets aside for the time being
then we see him talking about looking in
another place for wisdom
and this is
augustine's involvement with uh what you
know at that time was actually a world
religion
manichaeism which we don't want to spend
too much time on it but we'll say this
money
was
a religious innovator who
blended together elements of
zoroastrianism christianity buddhism his
own teachings some gnostic stuff and
came up with an entire complex system
that then spread uh all over the ancient
world and indeed became a church in its
own
right
um and augustine you know saw this and
thought maybe they have some some wisdom
there and so he becomes involved with
the manichaean community
and their teachings
and he's you know he says listen these
these people i wanted truth they're
talking about truth
although he says um
their names uh meaning jesus christ and
the paraclete the holy spirit were never
absent from their mouths but they were
only the tongue sound
and clatter while their hearts were
empty of truth
how can you get truth from somebody who
doesn't actually have truth this is a
key question they were always saying
truth truth many times they said it to
me but it was never inside them they
spoke falsehoods not only of you namely
god who are truly truth but even of the
elements of this world your creation
they they you know bought into this
gnostic idea that creation is
fundamentally bad it's like a prison
we're trapped in it we want to be freed
of it so we can rejoin god who is
entirely outside of this world and there
were aesthetic practices and all sorts
of other things designed to help you do
that
so that's what the manichaeans are
providing him with and augustine talks
about what it is that they
provide by way of teaching or doctrine
and he calls these
splendid
fantasies in latin
phantasmata
now this is a technical term in
philosophy
meaning you know the things that are
imagined or appear to us but they're not
really
what they are
and so he says
truth truth how intimately did the very
marrow of my mind sigh for you while
your men
these men boomed forth your name at me
so many times in so many ways
such were the platters on which the sun
and the moon your beauteous works but
still only your works and not you
yourself were brought to me while i
hungered for you i'm hungering and
thirsting for these things and then he
says but they still they put before me
on those platter splendid fantasies now
this is a metaphor about eating
and about being fed and
there's a great play on words in english
they fed me
these things that is they put them in
front of me they're giving to them to me
as nourishment but
these things did not feed me what
they're giving me
doesn't satisfy this demand this desire
that i have within myself for
real truth and he goes on and says
um
these are like food and dreams food and
dreams is like the food of waking people
but sleepers are not fed by it they
merely sleep those fantasies were in no
wise similar to you god uh why because
they were corporeal fantasies false
bodies and real bodies whether in the
heavens or on earth so they're giving
him a cosmology
and a metaphysics that turns out to be
false and their picture of god is also
likewise false
and then augustine is going to say
something really
interesting that requires a little bit
of unpacking if you don't know what he's
referencing so he tells
us
the readers that
and also him talking to god
that it would better it would be would
have been better for him to have focused
on the story of medea right a verse and
a song and medea flying aloft what is
medea flying a lot okay so madea was one
of the great
imaginary figures of antiquity she's
supposed to be from caucus she betrays
her own people kills her own family
out of her love for jason the argonaut
as supposedly a hero jason is actually
not very heroic
and they
leave with the golden fleece jason has
his kingdom
they actually have some kids together
and then jason decides that he's going
to put madea and her children aside and
marry a local princess
kind of start over again in midlife and
medea is so angry she's actually used as
an example of fumos anger uh
rage and she um
you know kills the princess
kills the children flies off in a
chariot she'll actually marry somebody
later on down the line in the story but
this is this is viewed as like a
cautionary tale and it's also you know
mythological augustine says that's it
it'd have been better to focus on these
made-up stories like that than on other
made-up stories that are pretending to
be true about the five elements right um
if you're curious about what the five
elements are you know perhaps this is
what aristotle's talking about with the
quintessence being
ether and the five elements
corresponding to the five dens of
darkness which are completely
non-existent
and he says um
you know at least
medea isn't pretending to be a real
story this is pretending to be
how things actually are
and it's false so it'd be better for me
to have
rejected that and augustine is going to
stay with the manikins and we'll talk
about this elsewhere for for quite a
while and
um
suffices to say that he actually bought
into the manikins for a while and he had
to see what they had to offer
in book four we see another attempt by
augustine to
acquire and live according to wisdom he
engages with these
what he calls imposters who they call
astrologers why because they offered no
sacrifices and directed no prayers to
spirits for the purpose of divination so
you know augustine doesn't like that
idea let's we shouldn't try to contact
the spirits but
astrologers
they seem to have a system
they say well the stars up in the
heavens
those influence our fates and they
determine
who and what we are
so
uh he goes on and he and he says
they say things like the cause of your
sinning was fixed unchangeably by the
heavens and the planet venus or saturn
or mars has done this meaning that the
human being made up of flesh and blood
and proud corruption is free from fault
and that the creator and ruler of the
sky and the stars must bear the blame
and he says well who's that but but you
god right so the astrologers are not
just like giving you little bits of
advice like you will you will have a
good meeting today or something like
that they're telling you about really
important stuff and they're shifting the
blame from the human being who screws up
to
the stars and thereby to them planets
and thereby to
god
now augustine runs into a guy who
actually studied that stuff for a while
when he was younger and then decided to
leave it aside and focus on
medical studies
you know he's a certain man wise most
highly skilled in the art of medicine
renowned for it who has pro-consul
placed by his own hand upon my foolish
head the crown one in a contest so this
is a guy who's got a lot of got a juice
right as we say a lot of pull
and he's talking with augustine he's
saying why are you into that stuff it's
not really effective by the way when i
was younger i was into it and i found
that it was it was bs
and so
you know
augustine is getting some useful
counsel by him that he should put this
stuff aside
and he says listen you've got the
profession of rhetoric don't pursue this
other stuff focus on your studies that
you can actually
do something with it and then augustine
asks him some questions when i inquired
of him why it was that so many of the
things that the astrologers foretold
turned out to be true
he answered as far as he could
what it's chance man
this is just things
turning out the way that they said and
you know augustine doesn't bring this up
but we have a uh identifiable bias where
we say oh look you know
in 10 of the cases what they said
actually turned out to be true and then
we ignore the other 90 of the cases
where what they said what they predicted
turns out to be false right we have this
bias towards looking for the success
stories
and this is basically what the guy
is saying to him if a man consults at
random some poet who sings and thinks of
things far different a verse often
appears that is wonderfully appropriate
to the business at hand
this is us reading meaning into things
that's not really
there and so that's something that
augustine himself is going to
leave behind we get to the end of this
and we see that augustine has not yet
figured out where he's going to get
wisdom from but
the desire for it has certainly been
aroused awakened
and affected
you